hi guys scifi recapped here
before we start warning
spoilers ahead today i'm gonna explain a
1973 american action and thriller movie
called terminal island
this movie tells a story about a group
of criminals sentenced to death that are
exiled to a remote island and establish
their own rules to survive
the movie begins with people planning a
tv program about terminal island a
remote island that served as a prison
for criminals sentenced to death for
first-degree murder
inhabitants cannot escape the island and
they are left to survive in the wild on
their own
they virtually have no contact with the
outside world except when a new inmate
comes and when the police deliver their
basic supplies the tv people then
examine the profiles of the island's
inhabitants ranging from bank robbers a
doctor a phd candidate an unhappy wife
and many others
a newly sentenced carmen sims is sent to
the island while she is still on her way
she sees two dead bodies one floating on
the water and one washed up ashore
she seems shocked but manages to stay
calm and gather supplies for her
survival
a man dr milford approaches her and
although she is hesitant at first they
soon converse
carmen asks where everyone is to which
milford replies that they are just
behind the hill
she also asks for an explanation for the
dead body she saw earlier but he does
not give her a satisfactory answer
he leaves her and she soon falls asleep
the next day carmen reaches the
encampment where other inhabitants are
waiting for her
no one seems to warmly welcome her and
she soon realizes that there are two
people in charge bobby and monk
monk gives her a warning to not disobey
him there are three other women living
in the same hut joy lee and bunny with
the latter seemingly being mute
she can actually talk but stop doing it
since she murdered her parents
she squeaks when carmen takes a nap in
her corner causing carmen to come out of
the hut but is quickly pushed back
inside by the men she asks the women why
they are being kept like pigs to which
they reply that they are considered
property of the man and that they have
to satisfy their sexual needs
if anyone disobeys bobby and monk and
tries to rebel they either escape or are
killed
the rebels live somewhere on the island
carmen aspires to escape too but the
women tell her that the situation with
the rebels is no better than with bobby
and monk the following day carmen
participates in chores
she helps to plow the field and build
the stonewalled warehouse bobby and monk
ensure everyone is working hard and will
warn anyone who is slacking off
including joy lee notices carmen's hands
are injured but other men would not let
dr milford treat her and force carmen to
continue working in the evening they
need to serve the men while lee joy and
carmen have to serve several men each
bunny only serves bobby although tired
they still need to serve breakfast for
the men in the morning a fight breaks
out between two men but bobby lets them
fight until one is killed off because
that would mean there is one less mouth
to feed
they then dispose of the dead body by
throwing it off the cliff and go on with
their day
the women are washing clothes on the
river guarded by two men
unbeknownst to them the rebel groups led
by aj are watching them and planning to
kidnap the women they successfully carry
out their mission killing the guards in
the process
while discovering the guards bodies
bobby's men know that their boss is
going to be disappointed
meanwhile the rebels gather around the
campfire and enjoy a feast celebrating
their successful mission to capture the
women one of them dylan attempts to
approach joy but she repeatedly resists
because she is interested in another man
instead
the following day the rebels split into
small groups so it will be harder for
bobby to catch them
lee finds a rock nearby the river which
contains potassium nitrate an essential
ingredient for making gunpowder and hand
grenades sparking an idea for a plan of
attack
carmen finds a poisonous vine and
explains it to aj
by boiling the fruit the substance can
cause anyone to fall unconscious within
10 seconds which she knows from her
grandma who was interested in voodoo
carmen asks him why he would save the
women from bobby to which aj replies
that would make him feel less alone
on the other hand bobby grows impatient
with finding the rebels as monk could
not locate them
while practicing archery joy discovers
beehives nearby and gets the idea to
prank dylan
she lures him by taking a bath in the
river then when he approaches her she
rubs his body with honey
later she disturbs the nearby beehive
causing the bees to swarm out and attack
dylan he runs to the river making
everyone in the group laugh
suddenly bobby's men arrive in a fight
ensues
both sides suffer casualties but the
rebels can finally escape after setting
a trap that stabs one of bobby's men
carmen and cornell seem to grow closer
and spend the evening together
in the morning the rebels properly bury
kiki one of their fallen friends then
continue preparing for an attack on
bobby under lee's instructions some men
grind the rock and collect other
materials to make hand grenades
bunny wanders around looking for water
while she is drinking from a small
waterfall bobby's men capture her
she fights back hurting teal who
captures her he wants to kill her as
revenge but others remind him of bobby's
order to bring bunny back alive
teal does not follow his friends back to
the camp anymore and is killed by the
rebels who chase bunny after they
figured out that she is missing
meanwhile bobby sabotages the police
radio frequency using his makeshift
radio
he learns that the police will bring
them supplies tomorrow morning he
figures out a plan for the police which
involves bunny
at the beach bobby and his men tie and
beat bunny then leave her using her as
bait to the police who come ashore with
their supplies
meanwhile lee who observes the situation
from the top of the cliff decides to
call for help the police come ashore
drop supplies and are about to go but
they could not stand seeing bunny's
miserable condition so they free her
at the same time bobby's men seize them
from behind defeating them and taking
their machine guns
bobby orders one of his men ray to guard
the supplies at the beach while he heads
back to the camp to bring more men to
pick them up the rebels plan to find
bunny and capture the supplies so one of
them swims ashore and hides behind the
police's raft then shoots ray using
carmen's poisonous vine he drops
unconscious after 10 seconds allowing
the rebels to capture the boat and
supplies
they take the jars containing fuels that
will be useful in their plan later
milford finds bunny and consoles her
she tells him that she wants to go home
the first time she speaks for a long
time
bobby and monk find rey is now dead and
they panic
they know the rebels are smarter and
stronger than them despite being
outnumbered as usual the rebels spend
their evening together around the
campfire this time exchanging personal
stories
milford explains that he once put his
patient to death as it was what the
patient wanted but his family refused
and accused him of murder he concludes
that even though he has a chance of
going home he does not want to because
of the trauma and would rather stay on
terminal island with his fellow inmates
in the morning the rebels head for the
camp
they find it empty realizing that bobby
has anticipated their attack but they
remain cautious
joy and milford instruct bunny to wait
for their signal to throw the grenade
and open the gasoline jar that will burn
bobby's bunker which is the stonewalled
warehouse they built earlier cornell and
lee bomb the makeshift toilet to test if
the grenade works which succeeds
wonderfully
slowly bobby's men start appearing from
their hiding spots and another battle
ensues cornell gets hit by bobby who is
hiding in the bunker with his machine
gun saddening carmen
lee throws another grenade to lure monk
out and distract him from protecting
bobby but she does not survive bobby
shooting however monk survives the
explosion although his left leg is badly
injured he crawls to bobby's bunker
knocks on the door and begs him to let
him in bobby fires blindly wasting his
ammunition
after nearly all of bobby's men have
been killed joy signals bunny to do her
job but she only stares blankly at the
battlefield
one of the impatient rebels goes to her
but is quickly hit by bobby
bunny reaches her fallen friend and is
shot in the arm as well
milford goes forward completing the
mission and evacuating bunny to safety
the gasoline runs through the wooden
planks and reaches the bunker then he
lights a fire that burns the whole
building
bobby burned alive attempts to escape
but could not be saved
meanwhile monk's eyes are heavily
injured and he cannot see anymore
aj carmen and other survivors pity him
and let him live
some time later monk now lives with the
rebels with bunny helping him to know
directions
after helping monk sit down in front of
the fire bunny takes milford to the
beach where the police come
the police explain that milford is
expected on land for another trial not
recognizing that milford is actually
standing in front of them however he
replies that milford is already dead he
then tells bunny that lee was right he
would rather be on this island than face
another trial
the police also bring a new inmate dana
which bunny and milford welcome warmly
subscribe to watch more videos like this
turn on notifications and leave a like
to help the channel out thank you for
watching